[Music]
fauci was warned
but the emails were scorned the
washington post a paper cat
obtained hundreds of pages of dr anthony
fauci's emails from the early days of
the pandemic
aside from the usual requests for nudes
they reveal correspondence with foreign
and domestic health officials
there really weren't nudes i was just
seeing if the audience was listening
in january of 2020 one scientist warned
him that the virus had some unusual
features
and looked engineered in mid-march
physicist eric a
nielsen wrote to fauci saying china had
been lying about their death toll adding
quote
the data posted by china is not only
garbage it has misled the world into a
false sense of security
vis-a-vis i never get to say that word
death rate
and age versus death vis-a-vis i truly
believe the outbreak
tsunami in the usa is either already
happened or is about to happen
now that's just part of the email it
went on for several pages which
apparently fouchy didn't have time for
because he forwarded the email to a
member of nanih
writing too long for me to read
too long for me to read that would be a
great name for his book
[Laughter]
[Applause]
if whoops wasn't already taken by andrew
cuomo
well we've all been there i usually stop
reading emails at
send five thousand dollars so you'll
never see cat timf again
then she's still here you attack cat
every time i can't help it spread it
around
i can't i can i can't spread around
because he can reach me and kill me
her little pointy arms they can't do to
me
i i wouldn't be worried about him
getting up i mean i'm literally in a
wheelchair and he's the only one here
with a better chair than i have
i don't know how this decision was made
you wouldn't enjoy it all right i got to
finish this
but the physicist was right china says
they have approximately 4 600
dead from coronavirus that's as
believable as hillary clinton's southern
accent
and in another different email a
researcher whose non-profit steered
money to the wuhan institute of virology
thanked fauci for dismissing the wuhan
lab leak theory early on
calling fauci brave for dispelling myths
about the virus origins
well like the cast of friends that
didn't age well
such a great line i think i'm just gonna
stop
right there do you think do you think
kaylee
chyna should build a statue of fouchy in
tiananmen square
yes thank you thousand percent but look
this man which by the way great title
too long to read that is hilarious so
too long to read the china email warning
about a tsunami of kovid
but let's review what fauci did have
some time to email
he had the time to respond to a friend
who said your face is on donuts and you
have a cult-like following and they ran
out of fouchy donuts
to which fauci replies i can't wait for
this to end
yeah right he's enjoying it he's a
megalomaniac then he
he he emails a friend and says they said
i look like brad pitt on snl
that made my day and my favorite one is
when he sends out a headline that says
crush cuomo
and fever falci the sexualization of
these men
is real that's what the america's top
infectious disease expert was doing
during a pandemic yes yeah well you know
what he loved it but
i didn't know about donuts these are
like fouchy donuts
they're holier than thou they are
what this is why i have a show when i
come up with things like that tyrus
is it not undeniable is it not
undeniable it is undeniable that only
you could come up with that you are 100
right uh uh i find this
tragically disgusting um you had time to
throw out first pitches you had time to
do every tour on every tv show and be
praised and
but you didn't have time to read the
email which was ex was specific to your
job
right one of the things that science and
doctors are supposed to do a lot of is
reading
that's true that's like their number one
thing you had one job
you were in charge of infectious
diseases and how to control we had
something
sparked off and you passed it off
to say it's too long to read there was
no other
follow-up email so what did you come up
with was there anything into it
do i need to check it back where is that
he literally
dismissed it because it wasn't important
to him when it was supposed to be
important to him
yeah so just like we like to go and and
it the glove fits in this one this ain't
an o.j situation
what cuomo and what he did with the
nursing home yeah there needs to be the
same
same attitude towards fauci and how he
ignored right
red flag signs yo look at me
there's a problem here and he just let
it go because he
wanted to be he's famous and he also
indulged he indulged the guy
that was involved in all of this stuff
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else